i have a question sure uh have you ever
played catalan with white
with white i have that's not ever been
one of my main openings
i played against it for many years i've
i've hated playing against it because i
didn't know what to do against it oh
yes like i play catalan and if you play
really
well yes it's so you play catalan as
white
yes oh so i i have a line i like to play
against it
which line so you play c4 right yes
i'll play e6 you play g3
uh you mean c5 here
i don't play c no i play i play d5 uh d5
okay so i'll take
it's going into um a bit more specific
theory
i play c5 here
well uh yes like this is oration which i
don't like with
when i play with white probably like
them bishop before and then
a3 like i mean when i try these bishops
like
literally
yeah there's a lot of tension between
the bishops between the pawns
i usually castle here
and yes so remember i'm just going to
take it and then play four
yes i mean this is variation which my
opponents are playing really rare
like oh i could show you one trap here
actually
okay yes for white i remember i played
some world youth championship and i i
got this position my opponent played
queen c2
and i reached out my hand about to play
a losing move and then i saw myself like
i realized right before
touching uh the pawn that i wanted to
move it was losing
i wanted to play b5 here
as a catalog player um it's actually
kind of a thematic idea
when black plays b5 to defend the pawn
yes uh white to move and punish black
we're like um well
uh this is i i see already
yes some people in chatham
yes yes they see it too yes
yes niger five so the the thing to
address knight e5 is a typical move
to try and win the rook but then like d5
and knight d5 yes
um e4 would then block the bishop but
knight g5
unleashing the bishop and preventing
knight d5 because mating so that's why
queen c2 is a bit tricky
i think here's similar ideas after b5
like knight g5 because it's
it's the most common to protect this
phone on c4
right yeah and usually what black has to
do here is just give away the pawn
and what i end up playing in the game uh
would be recommended is to play a5
just support b4 and then b6
and black will complete development and
when game continues
so i could sh i could share one trap
like one of the main traps in
in this line maybe it would be useful
for some players
uh who maybe want a weapon against the
catalan
um if we think about after bishop d2
c5 what white's options are
one of the most natural continuations
is just to take the bishop and queen e4
and just try and win back
the pawns and lionel show is
probably one of the most natural looking
continuations
for a catalan player
let's imagine knight c6 what's the first
move that comes to mind for white if you
want to win back material
95 95. that's so typical
it looks like everything's kind of
crumbling now for for black
we calmly play bishop d7
now of course white has maybe some
choice but we are threatening
knight takes d4 so many times white will
take on c6
so imagine white takes everything on c6
so winning back upon
let me ask you what what pawn would you
take here just first instinct
and check and participate
well
i would take him
he has a lot to take on c6 but
i mean i'm afraid of some traps like
uh crazy six ninety seven quincy four
here is rook c8
ah okay so you use fathers that's why
you take queen before
okay very very nice yeah there are a
couple people in my chat saying oh just
win both pawns yes um but
this is this is the whole point of the
line yeah white does win back
white's up a pawn here but is losing
either the queen or the rook
that's nice uh it's a nice line like it
flows very nicely
where white kind of just played the most
natural he moves and then
ends up losing so
[Music]
all of the traps we're addressing i've
i've had like in online games
it's it's so much fun where you you just
play what you've
you've studied in the past you don't
have to think in the opening and
people stumble into your your uh your
danger zone
so i should note this um i think this is
unofficially
[Music]
referred to as a ray robson variation
it's um grand master he streams from
time to time
a good friend of mine but he he played
this
back when he was maybe 14 or 15 it was
really
uncommon like almost a novelty type
variation
and he had some really incredible wins
in this line
so it's it's nice when you can kind of
play an offbeat opening and then keep
the game in your comfort zone
uh especially against like these
mainstream openings that you might
encounter
uh quite often again hopefully this is
of some
some value to people um it's always nice
to like acknowledge these traps so you
like maybe you could use them but also
you won't fall into them
um just good to be aware of uh
of the tricky ideas
i still have to play budapest why do
skiers like
linear equations why because it's easy
to find the slope
oh i understand that one
what's the equation for slope mx plus b
or no oh m is a slope though
i think it's been so long
it's been so long since i've been in
school okay i'm playing a ray robson
variation
of the catalan
yeah c5 is like the start of the the
variation
this used to be super rare it's been a
bit more common recently
um yeah queen a4 is a move and 95 is
kind of expected
and white's going to win a pawn probably
or multiple pawns
there goes all my pawns there goes this
pawn
there's a funny trap though yeah this is
this is a funny trap black is winning
now
this is all opening preparation i
discovered this line
close to 10 years ago inspired by ray
robson
i think i discovered this with the
engine actually years ago
okay how to exploit the king if i play
queen g5 there's f4
just play queens yeah
i have to calculate the slope of of this
diagonal
oh rise over run oh so the slope of this
is just
one right
i think
uh what's hanging oh i have a tricky
move
look at this tricky move it takes eye
pin
and then probably win
meanwhile the queen's tied down to the
knight which is now undefended i have
knight b3
i'll play knight p3 first white's pieces
are just sidelined
the king is a little bit stranded
i'm queen c7 here
oh i forgot about that move like this
move
these pieces are stuck i'm throwing made
in one
also probably the pawns yeah the d4 pawn
is hanging
that's a nice opening it's a fun opening
against the catalan you need some
preparation
but there's a lot of lines where white
can fall victim just like this this is
probably one of the
like the most natural approaches for
white is to like
try and win the back the pawn like this
is very typical
catalan play and then that's unfortunate
for white that this just
wins on the spot for black